if you're in between jobs here's maybe
what you can look for so here's one
chart that shows the 10 industries that
will pay you a higher salary salary soon
and the 10 that probably won't this is
according to morgan stanley if you're
not familiar with morgan stanley they're
one of the biggest investment banks in
the country they tend to kind of know
what they're talking about yeah this is
a business insider story so basically
the stories hovers around
wage risks for companies so this isn't
so much
for the individual person but you can
basically extrapolate what this
basically means for you but they're
basically warning industries or
companies within industries hey you're
probably gonna have to pay up a little
more soon right and other
companies look you can probably keep
wages where they're at how you doing
okay let's pull this up so this is wage
risk for companies will go through them
so if you're in the top 10 industries
you're going to have to raise wages so
everything in blue at the top these are
industries that are more than likely
going to have to
raise wages why
why because these are the ones that are
hardest to find employees these are
sectors that are basically raising wages
because they were the hit the hardest by
the lockdown so the leading at the top
of these industries are hotels
restaurants and leisure this has
obviously been shut down people have
left their jobs they've quit their jobs
they're basically saying in order to get
these people back you're gonna have to
pay more than 12 bucks an hour you might
have to pay more than 15 bucks an hour
you might have to bump up your wages
yeah okay
hotels restaurants real estate
management development commercial
services and supplies leisure products
textiles apparel luxury goods multi-line
retail specialty retail basically retail
retail retail retail
energy equipment defer diversified
consumer services and food and staples
retelling um
retailing exactly so retail
leisure restaurants basically a lot of
jobs that involve you having to interact
with other human beings yeah that people
basically got fired or they quit their
jobs they're basically saying to get
those people back
you're gonna have to show them the money
where's the money show me the money so
basically on the bottom half
of the chart we're basically saying rage
wage risk is going to be lower meaning
you're probably not going to have to pay
these people more you get gas utilities
beverages insurance pharmaceuticals
electric utilities water utilities
tobacco
diversified telecommunications services
oil gas and consumable fuels independent
power renewable energies those are all
basically jobs where you don't have to
basically interact with a lot of other
people you can maybe work from home you
work in your office you work in the
corner you're not doing a lot of retail
interacting with people you're not
working at bars you're not working
hotels so essentially it's
this is a supply and demand thing guys
let's just absolutely let's just get
into the bottom line here this is supply
and demand so it's a class example so
basically when supply
is
um i'm sorry when demand demand is low
right supply on the other end of side of
things so basically they're saying look
there's a lot of us that have worked in
this industry
uh there's demand for us to come back
show me the money give me the money show
me the money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken